the problem we're already seeing
firsthand the devastation climate change
causes from heat waves and droughts
to wildfires and hurricanes and unlike
many other global challenges the
solution
to climate change is clear
it lies in consigning dirty fossil fuels
like coal to history
in ditching gas-guzzling modes of
transport
and recognizing the role that nature
plays in preserving life on this planet
and harnessing the power of nature
through renewable energy rather than
orchestrating its destruction
if we don't act now
the paris agreement will be looked at
in the future not as the moment humanity
opened its eyes
to the problem
but the moment we flinched
and turned away
we've seen some progress in the last few
days and weeks
saudi arabia australia and russia have
all made net zero commitments meaning 80
percent of the global economy will wipe
out its contribution to climate change
by the middle of the century up from 30
percent thanks to the uk's cop 26
leadership countries such as the united
states have doubled their spending on
climate aid
every nation at this weekend summit will
end the financial support for
international unabated coal projects by
the end of this year
but these commitments welcome as they
are
are drops in a rapidly warming ocean
when we consider the challenge we've all
admitted is ahead of us
just 12
g20 members have committed to reach net
zero by 2050 or earlier
barely half of us have submitted
improved plans for how we will cut
carbon emissions since the paris summit
in 2015 and we've also failed to meet
our commitments to provide 100 billion
dollars a year to support developing
countries to grow in a clean and
sustainable way the un says emissions
will rise by 15
by 2030 and they need to halve
by then
the countries most responsible for
historic and present present-day
emissions are not yet doing their fair
share of the work
if we are going to prevent cop 26 from
being a failure then that must change
and i must be clear
that if glasgow
then the whole thing fails
the paris agreement will have crumpled
at the first reckoning
the world's only
mechanism
viable mechanism for dealing with
climate change will be held beneath the
water line
right now the paris agreement and the
hope that came with it is just a piece
of paper we need to fill that piece of
paper to populate it with real progress
and i i know
that humanity has
in it the power to rise
to the challenge
the uk has proved it can be done we've
lowered our greenhouse gas emissions by
44 in the last 30 years whilst
increasing our gdp by 78 and we're
cutting our contribution to climate
change more and more every day
we've made some progress of this g20
we've had a reasonable
g20
but there is a huge way still to go
we all know
that we have
the technology
what we need to do now
is to raise the finance but above all we
need the political will in glasgow to
make those commitments and to keep alive
the hope of restraining the growth in
our temperatures to 1.5 degrees thank
you very much and see you in glasgow
i'll go now to
questions from the media i'm going to
start with robert peston of
itv robert
prime minister you sound
extremely gloomy
about the prospects
for enough progress being made in the
next couple of weeks to limit global
warming
uh you say there's been progress by g20
countries but not enough
realistically
what more
can
be done
and
and separately there's been a bit of
confusion today about whether there has
been
progress in de-escalating the conflict
with france how do you see it oh thanks
thanks very much
uh
let me just say first of all on where we
are with uh with the g20 on climate
change as i said i think it's been
reasonable i think countries at the g20
have made a big effort and uh we've got
commitments by all g20 countries to uh
to net zero by the middle of the of the
century and if you remember when the uk
started off on this uh we had only two
countries that were committed that that
went up to
17 under uh the uk's uh cop 26
leadership and
we're now at uh at all g20 signed up
we've got
everybody committed to trying to keep uh
1.5
alive and and we've got everybody
agreeing that from the end of this year
no new
financing of international call
but robert what everybody needs to do
now is recognize that there are
granular commitments that countries need
to make on those those four bucket areas
of coal cars cash and trees uh that will
help us to go further
and make the reductions that we want to
see otherwise i'm afraid that the the
increase in temperatures will be
considerably in excess of 1.5 degrees
and that's the that's the challenge i'm
not going to
to
sugar coat it i'm not going to pretend
it's other otherwise than it is i think
there's a chance i really do i think
there's a chance that we can make the
progress everybody can see how to do it
it's a it's a question of of will and
leadership and on on um where we are
with uh our french friends i i want to
stress that we again we've had good
working uh with emmanuel macron his team
on cop really fantastic work on the on
on
green technology the french uh do an
extraordinary job as as everybody knows
particularly with their power generation
systems their commitments are
are excellent on
on nature on their nationally uh
determined contributions i support uh
what emanuel is doing on his one planet
initiative on fish i've got to tell you
the the position is is unchanged and uh
you know i will i'll just i'll just i'll
just say this uh for the for the record
i i must say i was puzzled to read a a
letter from the french prime minister
explicitly asking for britain to be
punished for leaving the eu
and i i just have to say no i don't
believe that that is compatible either
with the uh the spirit or the letter of
the withdrawal agreement or the or the
trading cooperation agreement that's
probably all all i'll say about about
that one uh just a very small thing on
the communique conclusions it says net
zero on or around 2050
many think that is a bit too vague yeah
well i i i
agree and that is a function really of
the
uh the the
the gap between
uh
some colleagues and and others some
countries as you know have made
commitments to uh to 2060 rather than uh
to 2050. we want what that what they've
said is 2060 or earlier
and what we want to do is uh bring that
those commitments earlier can we go
thanks robert very much uh laura
kunsberg of the bbc
um thank you very much prime minister um
what chance do you think you really have
of making progress with 200 countries in
glasgow when you haven't made enough
progress with 20 countries here and you
don't seem able to sort out the question
of a few dozen fishing permits with one
of your closest allies with the french
and what did you say to president macron
i mean the government's been explicit
very unhappy about the threats that
france has made what did you say to him
i i think that the
chances of progress in in glasgow as
exactly as i've said laura i think they
depend on
the the will uh the courage the the
leadership of everybody in the room and
uh you know it's not just
governments that that wants it or
governments like ours that are putting
pressure on on those leaders it's it's
their it's their their their voters
their citizens
and they want us to fix this and there
will be people in glasgow uh when the
our the delegations arrive tonight and
and tomorrow from the g20 who will be
who will be anxious who will be uh
absolutely desperate for our our uh cop
26 to make the progress that they want
so uh
i think the pressure on uh the world is
enormous i hope that they will agree uh
but you know as i as i stand before you
uh again tonight as i said to you when
we came out here to to rome uh laura i
you know we i think we have made
reasonable progress at the the g20 all
things considered but it is not enough
and what did you say to president macron
we had a a wide wide-ranging and uh and
frank discussion as you expect between
uh long-standing uh friends and very
very close allies
thanks uh let's go to
uh peter walker of the guardian
thank you very much um you've talked
about leadership and countries needing
to show that
and you've talked a really really good
game
but in the budget just gone fuel duty
wasn't raised um
and and um you know there's other things
that you could have done too
is it is it
possible that countries will see
policies like that and policies like
cutting foreign aid a lot of which went
to developing nations helping them fight
climate change and think well if he's
not going to do it then i don't see why
we should
well peter first of all on on on foreign
aid uh as you heard from rishi in the
british chukwu in the budget were the
growth in the economy means that
actually we're going to be able to get
back up to our our commitments on
foreign aid which are by the way uh the
highest i think of any partner in that
room uh except possibly for for germany
already so so you know i don't think
people really doubt the uk's commitments
on uh on on foreign aid on
um
fuels fossil fuels in motor vehicles and
taxes on that what the uk is doing
actually is going way out ahead of the
pack in uh in getting rid of of
hydrocarbon internal combustion engine
vehicles uh by 2030 and and we we set
the pace for that we were ahead of the
of the rest of the eu that's the that's
the the really important thing and i i
think also when it comes to the
credibility of the uk people can people
can see what we what we've done we cut
co2 emissions by almost
half
on 1990 levels already that's you know
cutting c2 by almost half for a major
industrialized country um
and our economy grew by 78 percent
44 cut so far and we're committed under
this ndc
to to do 68 percent cuts uh by 99. that
is a very very punchy uh target indeed
and uh
people know that we can do it and they
they know that uh we are determined to
do it and they can see the the progress
that we've made so i think that you know
without being preachier or uh you know
or or sounding uh
virtuous uh we can point to a pretty
impressive record by the uk and indeed i
i heard a bit of that
in the room uh this afternoon
thank you
uh eleni courier for the times
prime minister the final communique of
the g20 doesn't make any mention of
phasing out domestic coal consumption do
you think that's killed the chances of
keeping 1.5 alive
i think that's a really that is the
important question
and uh did everybody catch it it's it's
about domestic coal uh use
and that's why going into glasgow we
need to make more progress on uh on coal
and
on domestic coal
and i think it can be done and you know
you've heard the commitments that that
some countries have made um
the uh indonesians have brought forward
their their targets uh but
you've seen what's what's happening in
uh in south africa where there's a a big
project now underway and i think it's
it's it's that
um
model that we really need to develop if
we're going to have a chance of cracking
this what needs to happen is that the
countries that really depend on coal
particles particularly uh the the less
uh developed countries the the countries
on the path of development they are
gonna need help and they're going to
need specific packages specific country
platforms in which we in the the richer
countries help them not just with
investment
but with the investment that triggers
the private sector to come in and help
them with the new green technologies as
well that is the answer it's not just a
question of using uh taxpayers cash from
the from the developed world to fund
this it's a question of using
our aid budgets using uh all our efforts
together as uh with the multilateral
development banks and and others to to
create the conditions
as we did with wind power in the in the
uk
with the strike price and the contract
for difference to get the private sector
to come in and that's what we've got to
work up now the time is is desperately
short but but that's what needs to
happen over the next few days without
more commitments do you think that kills
1.5 i think i think 1.5 is in the
balance very much in the bounds
currently let's be in no doubt currently
we are not going to to hit it and we
have to be honest with ourselves so
uh we've got to keep that we've got to
keep that hope alive
uh max colchester from the wall street
journal
uh prime minister why do you think that
your fellow leaders didn't respond to
your rallying cry to to make serious
changes regarding climate change and
what makes you so confident or
potentially hopeful that the moon music
will change at glasgow
um max i think that the
i think what most people would say
looking at what's happened today and
yesterday the g20 is if we have made
some progress we've inched forward um
there's good things in the in the
communique but
the if i had to answer your you know
your question directly what's what's the
thing that that that is going to to
unlock this the big solvent in so many
negotiations is money
and
i think that uh
what will make the the difference is
when the when the countries on the path
of development really feel that they are
going to be to be helped towards that
green technology in the way that i
described and so you know people are
holding out uh for that they want to see
how it can be done how they can be
helped and you know i passionately
believe that it's the right thing to do
as you know i think that the green
industrial revolution
in the uk will help us to deliver
hundreds of thousands of uh of great new
high-wage high-skill jobs and you can
see uh the evidence of that al already
but you know that's the
that's the work we have to do to
persuade partners around the around the
table
and was there talk during the summit
about increasing the amount of money
given to developing nations to around
150 billion dollars a year to try and
help that yeah i mean narendra modi
prime minister modi uh said you know we
should go everybody should go up to one
percent of uh of gdp on
uh on sustainable finance for the world
on green finance for the world
and
you know as
i've as i've just said the uk is is
already or or will be when we get get
back to uh 0.7 in 2024 we will we will
be uh and have been for a long time one
of the biggest
uh
as a percentage of gdp
um but to get if i mean the united
states of america is way down um uh you
know for the united states of america to
get up to one percent of gdp you know
maybe you talk about serious amount of
money uh now that is
uh
unlikely to happen you know let me put
it this way in the short term uh but
what you can do
is use the cash that we are putting in
to trigger the private sector investment
that's what that's what needs to happen
so yes there's a there's a big
discussion about money
but we'll have to see where we go
annalisa rapana of answer
yes prime minister so um would you say
that after this g20 meeting
um cough 26 has more chances of success
or perhaps even less and if you had to
put a percentage to that uh chance of
success right now as we stand what would
that be uh annalise i think i'm going to
stick with where i what i was saying to
you all before you know that you know
where i think it's sort of six out of
out of ten it's nip and tuck it to touch
and go
we we could we
we could do it or or
we could we could fail by the by the
middle of november i think what the
italian presidency of the of the g7 has
unquestionably done is a superb job i
mean really a superb job of uh of
organizing the summit uh keeping
everybody focused i mean i i think mario
has done a really first-rate job of
keeping everybody focused on the the the
the gritty issues that we that we face
and trying to get uh people to commit
and
and to make progress i i think that
we've made
reasonable progress we have certainly
not not gone into reverse i think as as
as i as i said i think we've inched
forward uh we've put ourselves in uh a
reasonable position for
uh for cop in glasgow but
it is it is going to be very very
difficult in the next few days but i you
know i certainly want to thank the
italian government and the italian
presidency for all their efforts thank
you very much everybody thank you thank
you thank you
okay so that is the prime minister
speaking after the g20 in rome and he
was also speaking a heads of cop 26 in
glasgow that's going to be over the next
couple of weeks or so let's take a
little look at what we has been hearing
in the last few minutes boris johnson
said that the science is clear that we
have to act now on half emissions by
2030. he said there can be no more
excuses
he said there has been some progress
ahead of cop 26 in recent days and weeks
he mentioned saudi arabia and russia and
he also talked about more money from the
u.s but he said they are drops in a
rapidly warming ocean
and he said basically what is needed
here to get a deal done
is the political will and to raise more
finances too let's talk to our
international affairs editor dominic
whitehorn who is in rome for us dominick
we're used to hearing it's just a prime
minister would be really bullish on
these sorts of occasions really
optimistic he wasn't quite there this
time was he
no this was a very sober rather gloomy
prime minister wasn't it and he says
it's been a reasonable uh g20 uh all
things considered he said but that's not
good enough he said and he says that uh
the next couple of weeks are going to be
very very difficult um so that's
his take on on the g20 i think we should
remind ourselves where we are in terms
of climate change really um the fact is
that if temperature rises can't be kept
to 1.5 degrees above pre-industrial
levels we're looking at uh climate
catastrophe we're looking at more
extreme weather more of the kind of
storms and floods and drought that have
killed many many people around the world
over the last few months alone and on
the eve of this summit we had a warning
from antonio gutierrez the un secretary
general saying that we're looking more
at 2.7 degrees at the moment even if all
the things have been promised up to now
which is a big if
are implemented and acted upon he said
that means we are careening towards
climate catastrophe the way you um come
down from 2.7 to 1.5 is you phase out
coal completely if coal has continued to
be dug out of the ground and burns
there's no chance of uh meeting 1.5 so
the hope was
today or yesterday or at least over the
next two weeks uh the process of phasing
out coal could begin the best the g20
funnel communicate can come with on come
up on that with that is that
an aspiration to phase out coal power as
soon as possible
you can also reduce emissions obviously
and the best that the final communique
can come up with that is the promising
meaningful and effective action to uh
keep emissions down to keep 1.5 degrees
centigrade as an ambitious or a live
target and the other uh main ambition
for this summit and the the two weeks
ahead is to set aside 100 billion
dollars that can be given by rich
nations the rich nations here to much
poorer nations to mitigate the cost of
climate change and to make them realize
and understand that it's worth them
staying on board and following the leads
given by uh the 20 nations here the
world's richest nations well we're still
nowhere near that 100 billion dollars
according to this communique the spin
that's being put on it by downing street
and government officials is that a it's
not as bad as it had looked yesterday
which is a very low bar given that
yesterday it looked like these talks
were going to fall apart completely but
also some consolation they're saying is
this promising to communicate of further
action being taken over the next decade
and what they're saying is that this
process of revising emissions and
targets every five years could be
brought forward to every three years
uh not just on common dark side but
methane as well so that's the kind of
consolation they're putting on it but i
mean a pretty frank admission there from
the prime minister uh saying that it's
in his mind as reasonable as it can get
but he's saying it's a very very
difficult challenge in the two weeks
ahead because if 20 nations 20 richest
nations can't do more here what is the
hope of 100 or 200 or so nations doing
better in glasgow
all right dominic bicorn